the 2017 time Person of the Year is the
silence breakers they make up the people
mostly women who have come forward with
stories of being sexually harassed or
assaulted in the workplace
over the past two months dozens of
powerful men have been accused of
harassment and it has created a national
conversation but as we learned last
month from our panel of five female
leaders in their respective fields
there's still some confusion about when
a line has been crossed I didn't know if
that was harassment and I looked back on
it now and yes it would be considered
sexual harassment I didn't I didn't know
that it was wrong I was in a position
where I had to just trust this man for
so many girls there is a culture of
silence around this because they don't
know what qualifies with us now as
Allison West an employment attorney and
Human Resources specialist she travels
all around the country to conduct
workplace harassment training including
here at CBS alison good morning we're
still talking about that training
session he taught us a lot of lessons
that I think people really didn't know
so start us off because people do seem
very confused in this climate what are
the definitions of workplace harassment
so there's two different kinds of
harassment one we call hostile work
environment so that would be when
conduct is unwelcome it's because of a
protected characteristic severe
pervasive and impact someone's work the
other is quid pro quo right which is
what we know roger ailes the allegations
right that will do something for me I do
something free that's right do you give
me the sex that I want and in exchange
I'll either give you something or I'll
take it away so it can be a punishment
as well so let's break down hostile
environment because I think that's the
one that applies to many to many people
that's first it has to be unwelcome
that's right so unwelcome or an offense
offensive some jurisdictions will say
that's so meaning we look at it from the
reasonable persons standard so not
everything rises to the level of being
unwelcome it has to be due to a
protected characteristic including race
gender sex age because of that yeah
because of that so national origin
there's a variety every state has
different characteristics as well but
yes it has to be because of that severe
or pervasive let me just have one thing
though I'm more of a sexual name
if it's sexual harassment yeah severe or
pervasive that's right so it has to be
really bad or ongoing so sometimes one
thing could be significant enough or
severe enough to violate the law now I'm
many company policies though are much
tighter tougher than this right one
instance could be means for dismissal
right that's exactly right so really no
good employer in our country is going to
have the legal definition in their
policy because why would you want the
the conduct to be severe or pervasive
yes so you come to me and you say
someone touched me and I'm like I will
just tell them to do it more so then you
can complain I mean you want to know the
first time right that was I think that
was interesting to me our company
policies are stronger than proving it
before the law our companies are trying
to protect us they don't want severe or
pervasive so if I were to go to
management and say this person tried to
kiss me or this person exposed himself
to me what would that mean
well obviously exposing oneself is so
significant so severe you know that
would be that's not a gray area not a
gray area
I mean to me as an employment lawyer
like that's a termination right if
proven that's termination a kiss could
potentially also violate the policy but
under the law there are very few
attorneys that would take a case for one
kiss got it just because it it would not
rise to the level typically of violating
the law one of the things we've learned
from these men and their past is that
they'd settled agreements right
non-disclosure agreements with women and
and paid the money and we're just now
hearing about them I think a lot of us
feel mixed about these agreements
because on the one hand a woman has a
right to be protected and not to have to
you know talk about her ordeal on the
other hand it doesn't really address
what the man is being accused of doesn't
stop to be yeah because he can keep work
right that's right and some states are
moving to ban these how do you feel
about this so my view is I think it
should always be up to what the
complainant or the plaintiff and their
lawyer think is best for them in that
situation I think a total ban would not
be helpful completely because what you
just said not everybody wants it aired
maybe someone made a mistake maybe
someone you know used poor judgment or
something and engaged in conduct that
they regret later on but by the same
token we have to be careful because in
the workplace you know your HR
department does not
about an email every Monday this week's
harassers you know these are private
confidential matters so even without a
non-disclosure agreement in the
workplace it's not as though we have
people talking about this right HR will
do a prompt and thorough confident you
know it's confidential as possible an
investigation so when does a complaint
rise to the level of moving from the
workplace to the courtroom because we've
all been in situation where you work
with people that are just jerks right
and you just say hey knock it off I
don't think that that makes him a sexual
harasser because he said something
inappropriate to me and I told him leave
me alone and that's the end of it so
when does it go from the workplace to
the courtroom because I think a lot of
people a lot of people are being labeled
sexual predators and really their
districts who are acting acting
obnoxiously
I think that's that's absolutely right
so look the goal is just stop the bad
behavior make sure it doesn't happen
again so exactly that hey stop that
behavior doesn't happen again
everybody's good if you go to HR or
whoever in your company and they don't
do anything to stop it you know in some
states like in California where I am you
have to go to either the EEOC or the
Department of Fair Employment and
housing you have to actually file a
charge of harassment or discrimination
or retaliation but people will go see a
lawyer I mean if you feel like the
behavior hasn't stopped then you're
gonna escalate it something else we're
hearing is that a lot of these accused
say they were consensual or they thought
they were consensual relationships and
that raises the question about
relationships in the office are they
frowned upon should they be just like
you know banned how should we
objectively approach this kind of
situation because one could say listen
you spend the majority of your day there
it's natural that you're gonna meet a
partner there as well well I think the
biggest issue is that a supervisor
should never have a relationship with a
subordinate I mean that's just going to
be frowned upon because it only ends two
ways marriage termination right because
it just it's so delicate but yes people
meet and many companies allow people to
date but you can't have that supervisor
subordinate relationship so when someone
says but but as someone who's a
supervisor says but it was a shared
relationship it was consensual can that
be that way but they have power and it's
very hard to separate the power and the
higher the power right if someone's here
and the the employees here
it it's it's very difficult to be able
to really affirmatively give consent
that and by the way that's not just your
opinion that happens to be CBS's policy
as well you're not allowed to have
relationship you have to report it to
management if you are having that's
exactly right and what they would do is
they would separate the parties do you
worry about theirs having a backlash
against women I've heard some men say
what now I can't ask you out I can't
mean to give you a compliment I can't
touch you on the arm just right you look
great
do you worry about that I do to the
extent that people are still confused
because not everything will be
harassment yes right so you touch
someone on the shoulder to comfort them
like typically that's just never gonna
be harassment right you keep doing it
you do the old baby baby on the shoulder
it changes it but yeah I think people
have to be comfortable saying no to
someone but I think people also have to
make sure I want to touch your shoulder
to go that everyone fit not everybody
likes it we're gonna have to leave it
there I was sure they had more time
would you come back every day there's
still so many questions you are very
busy very access thank you so much been
my pleasure thank you thank you